each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
sir with engineering research and
programs and on behalf of Jim lares it's
a pleasure for me today to have this
talk by learning leifer professor a
mechanical engineering design from from
Stanford and so he's also going to be
joined by Jan Chong fifth year doctoral
student doctor no student from the
department of management science and
engineering at stanford university over
the past year we have been contributing
to some of the research efforts for for
Larry's work at Stanford so without a do
like to present anchor thank you thank
you very much John partly for the
audience's information I'm very hard of
hearing guy when we get the Q&A use wave
your hand and I come up with my own
microphone and interview with the podium
this far from the screen I'm going to
tend to walk around I'm delighted to be
with you and I'm going to try to do a
little bit to entertain the the first
thing we'll try to do is to give you a
little bit of our background where do we
come from why are we interested in the
way people design build and operate
systems complex systems historically
more in the world of aerospace and
automotive industry and consumer
electronics that in the software itself
but increasingly the software because
it's now the biggest part of the product
and then Jen will present preliminary
results from study of pair programming
activity in which was specifically try
to get out that what are they doing and
why and the hidden agendas if
what they're doing and we understand why
then how can we help them do it better
on the third component of the
presentation is to share with you if you
sooo what's hot in the Stanford
community on getting out issues in
design and what I understand from the
mornings conversations you might prefer
to call software architecture versus
software design I think we're talking
about pretty much the same issue but we
have some different language for it and
often that's the beginning of confusion
in product development so where do we
come from and why the primary mission
that I have as a design engineering
educator is to redesign the future and
this image is a little bit of
biographical sketch on where I think the
future is headed I'm going to act it out
just a little bit when I went to college
that undergraduate I was kind of that
guy Harry right off the beach in
Southern California i denti had a
bachelor's degree and then a master's
degree actually better tell you what
this with general engineering science
like no major art and engineering what's
that neurosciences oh that's big this
guy's got our PhD he's going to be in
charge of the world he's got tools
you've got knowledge and then he gets an
assistant professorship and associate
professorship and the full profile the
whole life is a keyboard and what I want
to convey a little bit is the sense that
my students come in looking like that
and I'm really anxious about their
engagement in the world the quality of
life you're building to know and
understand at a large level broad level
of human values and potential versus
just things that come through keyboards
things that go through displays of
whatever scale and we know what the next
step is because we're already there
that's the next step now the keyboard is
that scale right so in fact I think this
is really a very very timely acute
concern for all of us if we don't get
out there and start redesigning the way
things are that's where they're going to
go and they've already got a five to
fifteen year lead on us so if we don't
start or in deep trouble and of course
changing a universe isn't easy so we
should start sooner and with more vigor
and you guys are part of that change the
universe scenario well we spent a lot of
time looking at the future in our new
product development group so I share a
little slide of a group you recognize
the icon for Audi would you believe that
Audi's vision of its own future is this
car as was made for the movie I robot
how many have seen iRobot that's good
your folks like me I go to movies like
that in the movie you might think that
that Android thing in the background is
the robot well and maybe it was but the
robot that really got my attention is
this guy because this guy is going to be
in my lifetime this guy is already on
the road parts of him and he's going to
have autonomy and he's going to have
intelligence and he's going to have
sensors and he's got an operating system
that never reboots or it does so quietly
and doesn't tell you right okay so we're
very concerned with the future and how
we should go about getting there one of
the ways we get at the future is to have
companies bring projects into the
university environment where we can
study how product development could be
made better it's a good little sampling
of what the projects look like
this year there's a strong automotive
industry representation because
automotive industry is desperate to
innovate and you'll notice from the
labels that the mostly trying to
innovate in the cockpit with electronics
with smarts with sensors with software
the most dramatic example is perhaps
outtie itself again they want us to
prototype the copilot for the year 2020
and a team is in the process of building
that right now and they've come to a
really wonderful insight they discovered
that and 2020 we don't need a co-pilot
because the cars got all the maps in the
world it's got GPS it's got cool totally
drive-by-wire computes its way down the
lane and doesn't go out you and I can
take a break what do we do with our
break we start doing the internet we
start doing SMS we're doing watching a
movie we're talking to our friends would
totally involved in communication task
and therefore it becomes the co
communicator of the future and the team
trying to build a system that actually
makes sense for that role
the other feature of our community is
were very engaged in delivering teams
not always unit teams but people are
completely prepared to be on teams to
launch new companies to invent new it
happening interfaces to the world to
produce water fountains that are the
greatest experience have ever had and
may be our best known spin-off is a
company named I do product development
now one of the leading companies of its
kind and a full seven times larger than
its clearest nearest neighbor so they've
become a real kind of flag pole for
where things could go or should go maybe
even sometimes shouldn't go let me try
with this image to represent what our
research group does it's a little
different than most technical
development groups in a typical scenario
let's invent the BMW of the future we
will get a group of product requirements
would give them to the product
development team they would produce
technical outcome specifications
performance data whatever and we would
feed that back in a technical loop to
monitor performance are we meeting goals
and requirements what we would not have
is instrumentation on the human element
in the product team so the stress and
the emphasis for you to see is sure we
do the technical loop we have to what's
novel is to instrument the product
development team itself so that it is
better able to perform its job it's not
that we're controlling them we're giving
them information about their own
performance so that they can make
intelligent choices and decisions
let me show one example of the kind of
project that happens in this environment
we're working with VW last year and they
wanted to explore the notion that the
drivers should be able to say close the
window or turn up the radio or keep that
person out of the car gestural interface
to the vehicle very early in the project
actually within about the first five
weeks of the project out of a 30-week
project we're in the car we're starting
to take over the cockpit or putting on
displays and sensors in place so that we
can begin to explore how would this
actually work in a car now just thinking
about it but being in the real world of
the customer and the group came up with
the notion of controlling the common
center console panel how do we handle
the AC how do we handle Windows
entertainment entertainment and this was
a zone in which they implemented a
machine vision system and I chose this
example because machine vision is your
business it's software engineering its
algorithms it's making sense of noisy
data trying to extract the signal from
the noise trying to make sense
the same software that you is there
wasn't part used in Stanley the Grand
Challenge winner so it's not like its
low-end stuff it's right off the top of
the cs department you put it in the
cockpit and it's really hard to get
reliable performance the team continued
to develop this and refine it and by the
end of the year yep we could operate all
those systems but we weren't very happy
howdy was very happy that we did it for
them and they didn't have to the second
of two examples I'd like to share with
you comes out of the world of software
engineering Electronic Arts one of my
doctoral students was employed full time
there had been there five years and he'd
been collecting data I'll let you read
that essentially for multiple cycles of
product development he had access
through all of the code not in the sense
of when it were checked out checked in
bug reporting and knowing who was
working with a code at any given time
the very intense development cycles very
real world industries scenario which a
footnote is very hard for us to get this
kind of data in the real world that's
extremely hard to get inside a company
people concerns privacy concerns
intellectual property good the fact that
he got it is fantastic so what so let me
try to walk you through his slide it's
not easy for me lines of edited code
timeline milestones first release
re-release the blue line is maybe the
background is the amount of code check
in and out you see it's very high level
of fluctuation the average wraps up over
about a month in a pretty steady state
and it goes right
John at that steady state that gets a
push you read that i'll let you do that
yourself okay this is one of the ones we
especially attend to and that you guys
probably feel special pain with the
feature creep scenario a different view
is to look at lines edited and the
moving average of how much of the code
was being edited so low versus
concurrent more than one person working
on that module or unit at any one time
so one of the things we learned about
group programming was it in these
initial typically highly formative
phases of a project but not the main
production phase but then they're
deciding what will be built and why and
then when we go down into production we
get this incredible ramp up to absolute
frenzy and madness and burnout they're
gone and then they take about a
two-month break before they even come
back to work data lots of data he's
still mining it it begins to give us
some insights into the dynamics of
software engineering with often attended
e-2c work and steady tape processes this
cries out how dynamic it can be that's
what we do and now a glimpse of what the
design thinking research has yielded
over the past 15 years or so we study
people at work and we try to figure out
what's blocking them and what would help
them our core methodology is simply to
observe this represents video
interaction analysis look at a team
doing their job record the video micro
analyzed the video when John presents
her work in a few moments that's a
similar scenario though she
wasn't using video the next example
comes from a field work we did at Ford
Motor Company I didn't say that out loud
that I we were invited to come and look
at what happened when they introduced a
new product development methodology into
the company the whole story behind out
but the new everybody does product
development the same way now folks and
they give that to a group of experts the
experts go to the product development
teams product developments try to turn
out the real car and we try to track
where the knowledge is there's knowledge
in a loop here people working together
lots and lots of tacit knowledge there's
the formal reports and documents to go
back into the corporation and management
and the thing that got our attention was
as a loop here coming through this
consultant process consultant and as a
result of this with formulated several
lines of research that look at this role
and the big issue in this domain is the
decisions that are made go up there the
reasons for those decisions are hidden
only the coach can see inside and report
outside so the key to capturing tacit
knowledge the rationale for things may
be actually in the hands of a real
person
okay one of the big findings this was
actually software development challenge
at xerox parc human-computer interaction
and john thong was wondering how his
information managed how is communication
managed so the big point was that his
store text yep no surprise you express
ideas with sketches not such a big
surprise either you mediate interaction
with gestures how many of you have a
computer that records gestures excellent
cool that's notepad okay right on well
remember adjuster with what we were
trying to do in the car to chester has
long been a missing signal with the huge
relevance to workflow negotiation their
own group work is a huge effect the next
piece i want to share with you was by
the nod biol he's in a studying a
situation where people are in a product
platform situation the last generation
product or vehicle subsystem now has to
meet new requirements and he's studying
how they used the information he's
looking at several versions of the
information how they produce at how they
retrieve it how they search for it but
the most compelling finding of all with
it no matter how they were dealing with
information they had an attention span
with a median of six seconds I suspect
that describes a lot of software
engineering if it doesn't work like that
I'm out of here I'm on to the next bug
things like that a very common in our
world and the better you are is shorter
your attention so the experts move this
to the left and novices move it to the
right
so our environments for supporting
design have to be very responsive this
one's a little more abstract but it's
really interesting we have a situation
in the course where the design teams I
should mention the design teams are
typically three to four people they
produce a final report after five weeks
after 15 weeks and after 25 weeks at the
full documentation of the product and
the process auntie momma gonggi was
looking for the question they asked and
it would difficult the fines ended up
counting noun phrases quick definition
of a noun phrase it's the screen height
the screen with the surface texture of
the line with the font shape anything
that's descriptive and he found a
distribution here he found that all
teams added more unique noun phrases as
they worked and continued to and after
living with this graph for almost two
years we finally saw the blue and the
red line some groups start off at a
lower level and they don't learn as much
they don't add new language and some
start higher and learn faster and these
are the high-performance teams to win
the prizes get their product on the
market these guys aren't bad but they're
the mediocre outcomes this was a huge
discovery that the language people use
while they're working is an important
metric of the progress being made in a
project and the last one I want to share
with you was from was great eunice's
work where he nailed the question issue
he did it by using video interaction
analysis incredibly time-consuming but
what he found was the performance of the
team was a function of the number of
questions asked per unit time
40 questions an hour that's a lot of
questions what kind of questions deep
reasoning questions that's analytic
thinking given some alternatives how do
we choose amongst them to produce
decisions and generative design
questions the questions we asked to
expand the design space figure out what
the options are and the alternative and
the two go together gotta diverge and
you gotta converge and you do that 40
times an hour this is an incredible
process and what we know indirectly is
that the decisions get recorded and the
questions don't so very often when we
try to get back at the rationale behind
what happened we don't know the decision
in response to a question big deal
hey we're part to let me introduce and
hand control to jen chung hua is maybe
you should describe briefly how you see
you all
okay hi my name is gentle and
many studies there
we go
for projects because an intern
sighs across from the computer science
from you
CTR is located in
motivation one of the started getting in
they're a handful of studies out there
pair pair programming forms basilica
and in general
there's a better fit
rainy
that English
but they're cute
compelling patterns that we want
but there to serve me
study there
the first one is
outcome measures
what happened
taking medicine that works
play our issues services of programmers
afternoon
well this one is definitely working
okay are we good all right so weird like
Oh looking inside the back box to
actually see what it is about to people
and what's happening what process is
going on that leads these better results
of these studies of documented the
second limitation is that majority of
these studies have been run on student
programmers because their academic
studies and because that's what's
available to them and not on
professional programmers so that really
raises the question of how much these
findings translate to professional
programmers working in a completely
different environment than what students
do in the classroom okay so when we
started this project this is a diagram
Larry came up with that kind of says
what's the difference between a pair and
the solo programmer and so the soul of
programmers can at the top like about
what does a he or she get in product
requirements and software specifications
and then what's the process that goes on
when they develop software right they
interact with the development
environment and the software code and
what's going on there we kind of
hypothesized that in this sense there
were two roles now we have the driver
and the navigator and there's all these
new feedback channels and interaction
channels that are going on between the
two programmers and so that's kind of
our starting point for thinking about
what's going on in these process so the
way we designed our project to explore
this is based on a lot of the other
research done at CDR the two-phase
project it starts with ethnographic
observations in the field followed by a
lab experiment that then is informed by
what we found in the field so I'm going
to talk about each of those phase this
is in greater detail and in particular
I'm going to really focus on the
ethnographic face because that's what
we've completed and have been busy
analyzing the data to date we're about
to start the lab phase and that's
something we wanted to get some feedback
from people here on is what they thought
we should do with this in particular so
phase one the actual ethnographic
observations occurred from april to
august of last year and what we did was
we found people in the workplace that
were actually pair programming as a part
of work and we watch them work i'll talk
a little bit about what we found about
that and then from September to pretty
much now what we've been doing
going over that data repeatedly trying
to identify what we see is interesting
and what we see is our hypotheses for
what's going on in there okay so how
many people here are familiar with
ethnography okay so not bad but not
everyone with her so i thought i'd give
a bit an overview what that is it's a
methodology that comes to us from the
field of cultural anthropology and the
main idea there is to strive to
understand the world from the
perspective of the people you're
observing and you do this through
intensive observation of what they're
doing their actions the artifacts they
interact with and their dialogue in the
context in which all these interactions
occur and so in practice what that means
as we sit behind people we take video if
it's possible that's often not possible
especially in an environment like a
professional software development
company and then we go through all that
data to try to find pattern so in this
case we conducted ethnographic
observations at two sites these were
mid-sized companies in Silicon Valley
two teams one in each company and in
this case pair programming was used as a
part of extreme programming we did try
to find pair of programmers that were
not in the context of extreme
programming but that proved difficult to
locate so both of our sites ended up
being pair programming in the context of
XP and if people are interested in that
I can talk a little bit about the more
XP side of things too ok so our two
teams are depicted here team a on the
right and Team B on the Left team a was
formed in January of 2000 for the start
of our observation period which is
between three to four months I Bluford
teammate was four months it had six
developers they had hired three more by
the end of the observation period one
full-time developer and two consultants
on this team pretty much all the work
was done in pairs every morning they
would meet have a status meaning to talk
about what they'd done the day before
form an ad-hoc pair and then they'd sit
down to get work done Team B it was a
little bit older it had been formed in
early 2002 sauce a little bit bigger and
nine developers they hired one new
developer by the end of the observation
period all the programming work on this
team
done in pairs but they had specific day
set aside for practices such as spiking
exploratory programming to look for
different solutions and testing which
they did by themselves so individually
okay so what do I mean when I say we did
no graphic observations well we visited
each of these teams weekly across a
combined total of five months for both
teams we spent about three months at
least with each theme each time we
visited we spent between 1.5 to 3 hours
with that team as actually ended up
being a bit longer than three hours for
teammate we'd often also go to lunch
with them or hang out with them a little
bit afterwards so that added to the time
when we were there we would usually sit
behind a particular pair of programmers
and basically just try to absorb
everything they were doing for that day
taking notes often as rapidly as
possible in order to capture as much
detail as possible noting both their
actions their dialogues in the context
for the action and dialogue we use audio
recording in order to better capture the
dialogue that was being spoken in the
course of programming which we then
would go home and transcribe and then
integrate those transcriptions with our
notes in order to get a very detailed
transcript of every single session and
so to give you an idea these are about
40 to 60 pages per session after that we
would go back and review them reread
them and then we something we call
coding which is not really what most
people think of its coding which is the
systematic identification and
categorizations of behaviors so the idea
here is that if we go through the data
and find something we think it's
interesting we want to make sure that's
not it using cratic to a particular
person or a particular session so we go
through all of the transcripts look for
that behavior and make sure that it's a
persistent pattern okay so some
provisional findings so what we came up
with is kind of this collection of I
think four or five I we call them
findings because they were really
documented by behavior in the field and
then three more there were more
hypothesis that's kind of informed by
what we saw going on the field about
what we think is interesting about pair
programming in some cases what makes
pair programming really work so our
first one here one thing that was
immediately obvious when we talked to
programmers the literature on pair
programming and in fact the developers
themselves when asked to describe how
pair programming worked would tell us
that well there are two roles that pair
programmers break up into one person is
the driver they control the keyboard
they kind of think about things at a
lower level of abstraction they're
really concerned with immediate
implementation issues figuring out what
code goes next what's the next line of
code and the other person is the
navigator and they kind of operate at a
higher level they sit back they offer
feedback make more strategically as a
phrase that was frequently used to talk
about how these roles worked on a
programming pair so in some sense it's
the gray lines on this diagram would be
what people constantly told us that they
were doing even the developers that
engage day-to-day on pair programming
now what we found when we were observing
them is that this isn't what they were
doing at all in the fact what they did
was there was no real separation in the
level of detail with which they
approached the problem that they were
working on in fact they were really
tightly coupled they would both have a
conversation at a very low level of
detail and then at some point one person
were maybe say like wait a minute it was
this really the issue that we should be
thinking about what if we conceptualize
this test as a X right and then they
would both kind of start being like okay
well you know if we think about that it
will interact with this module in this
way we can start Rican sexualizing it
and then maybe like let's try it out you
know let's take a look and so they were
kind of moving through this problem
space going between these levels of
abstraction but in a very in a way that
was very tightly coupled together so not
the sustained level of abstraction yes
so these guys are doing custom
development as well yes they reading
test and development its operation about
one person thinking about the task in a
person employed in a day
they didn't really I mean like he said
they kind of both worked on it at the
same time and thought about at the same
time so there isn't really the sense of
one person's like oh I'm going to write
it and the other person's like wait no
this is how it should go except I mean
out of a planning session this wasn't
always the case when there is a huge
knowledge disparity between the pair
then we did see something that was more
like one person is really driving
interaction the other person's thinking
about it on different level and giving
more distant feedback almost and but the
thing about that is this would occur
regardless of who had keyboard input
right so you could have the navigator
really being like okay what we need to
next line of code or into the level
where they would be like for I equals to
the other person so that kind of okay
okay so that was really interesting to
us because again it goes against
everything that's been kind of written
about pair programmers and in fact what
the the programmers themselves thought
they were doing so again to hear it
cigar initial conception was also
incorrect so we had you know something
else is going on here the second finding
again that we totally didn't expect we
didn't go into the study looking for
this but we did find was that
programmers are constantly interrupt in
the course of programming which those of
you who are programmers are family like
duh but you know it takes researchers a
little bit while to figure out what's
going on and what was interesting about
this and this draws on data from a
separate ethnographic study of solo
programmers that is also done in the
same organization as team a so they're
within the same company but two separate
teams one which is performing one which
does not is that the interruptions are
consistently shorter for the pair of
programmers than they are for the solo
programmers and so I kind of give you
some numbers here which is the total
observation times that we have that are
analyzable from each team the average
duration of the observed introductions
across the team the number in
parentheses is the number of
interruptions for each condition and
then what we did was to try to get a
picture of what's going on we broke them
down and we coded each of these
interruptions by both sores their self
initiate interruptions or externally in
ischia interruptions so if you stop work
yourself to do something else or if
someone comes
your cubicle to ask you a question
forcing you to turn away from your work
and address them or what type and
intrusion a distraction or a break and
across all of these categories the pair
programmers are always shorter average
than the soul of programmers and
sometimes like quite a lot yes uh-huh
the more of them yes why did they have
why why did the intrusion once he taught
to me is in that case i would say solo
programmers are better off they don't
get as many trojans and so I I just
seems like more well one thing he
remembers these papers were radically
co-located because again this is part of
the XP team so that adds a little bit of
noise in here but nevertheless that
which I think explains why they are more
interrupted they're in the same space
it's easier to interrupt someone you go
over and it's more distracting as well
but even in that space right they keep
their interruptions much shorter in some
sense you would think they would be
moving more distracted in that sort of
environment but no matter what happens
the solar program where's kind of I
misinterpreted because I bet everything
I I applied the cute this so that's what
we're in my mind okay hey what do you
mean who
no they had to product groups one of
them used XP and programming and the
other one did not the other one used to
modified water for watch the process
people worked in individual cubicles
know they had you know yes to every time
you're interrupted there's a context
which even while we doesn't get factored
overall numbers either mm-hmm so
probably those numbers are are greater
than the show yes the disparity between
the two teams is actually yes so we
could talk all day about this one I in
fact I more than happy to do that but
that's not what the toxicity on no but
feel free to ask me questions about it
later so there's a whole host of reasons
why we think that's true but kind of the
broader reason we have the spare
programs or more mindful of workflow and
then also tend to bring each other back
to task is kind of the general summary
on that we also looked at pairs when
they were talking and we noticed one
thing is that the pair's have an
overlapping but usually non-identical
pools of programming knowledge skills
and experience rights if you think about
you know one program has one of these
circles but two programmers has this
whole Venn diagram and some other
knowledge is going to overlap and that
means that they have easy ready access
to a much larger knowledge database
which probably allows them to produce
higher quality code more rapidly they
have access to different design patterns
more immediately knowledge about
particular parts of the code it's just
bigger for the two of them one question
that this raises is that what kind of
the right combination for two
programmers that are pairing right if
you kind of already by the pair for
everything I do you want people that
have a lot of overlap or very little
overlap this would seem to suggest that
little overlap is good but we know from
studies of interactions that you need
some sort of overlap in order to be able
to communicate in order to be able to
function as a parent so that's one of
the things we don't know right what
makes for ideal pairing a second one is
that the pair's would come in even if
they heard the problem the same way from
the same people or read the same docs
they still come away with inherently
different conceptions of the problem so
you know programmer one thing's it's
this concave
programmer to you think this kind of
contacting and before they can work
these pairs task that we would require
agreement on what the course of action
should be before programming and in the
course of getting to that agreement they
had to negotiate the problem boundaries
and the potential solutions and that
resulted in a very thorough search of
the solution space much more thorough
than what we saw solo programmers doing
again there wasn't supposed to be solo
programmers in studied fit I watched a
lot of them okay peripera members had
the ability which suckers do not engage
in continuous review at the design and
the code as an ax murders this is that
immediate feedback that you get from
simply having a second pair of eyes and
we did see them catching a lot of code
defects earlier in the programming
process ranging from very simple things
like you're missing a semicolon on that
line or you know their function name is
spelled wrong to larger things like wait
a minute how does this work in the
context of that module was this going to
break the module or the interaction we
already have program in there and then
moving onto hypotheses now these are
three things that we think are going on
but were kind of less able to prove
because of the data we had in the format
comes in one thing we thought relevant
to interruption is that pair programmers
seem to be able well first are they were
able to continue making task progress
even when one programmer was interrupted
by just you know inherent nature having
a pair one person gets pulled away the
other person continue making progress on
the task but two things we thought might
be work going on is one is that they
more recover more rapidly from being
interrupted because they were able to
serve as an interactive means for you to
return to the task so you think of it as
a solo programmer trying to pick up
where i was in terms of working all i
have is my state whatever you know
context i can remember what the physical
artifacts are on me indicate when i come
back to the compare well if I have a
partner I can just ask him or her you'd
be like you know where we'll be doing
what's going on and usually they do it
unprompted you sit back down and your
pair will say oh you know what I'm
looking at is this line here and I'm
trying to figure out X and so that
geez how rapidly you get back into the
problem the other thing we thought is
that they were socially motivated to
address inter interruptions more rapidly
than solo workers you have someone
waiting for you back at your computer
you're supposed to be working as a pair
right so you're going to kind of speed
things up in order to get back to the
person that you're supposed to be
working with so corollary to this as a
result pairs may incur less workflow
degradation over time due to interrupts
and while maintaining the high levels of
attention focus that they need to
produce top quality code so
interruptions may be less disruptive to
Paris than they are with solo
programmers hypothesis to has to do with
kind of cognitive load something again
drawn from both watching the programmers
and some a little bit of experience
ourselves when we tried to work in pairs
I mean spare pair gamers have an
opportunity to share cognitive load of
pair programming that means that when
you're sitting there if you have our
solo programmer may be making a lot of
effort high cognitive effort into their
work task but over time as they grow
tired they can't sustain that effort so
by a necessity it kind of like degrades
maybe you take a break here and so
therefore you're kind of getting
starting to come back up here if you're
working on particularly difficult or
taxing problem for instance well because
there are two people in a pair what you
can kind of do is switch off right you
can take breaks while your partner's
still kind of operating at a high level
what this means is that the pair of the
unit potentially sustains a much higher
level of cognitive effort across the
entire period of time yes what this
suggests is the two solo programmers
achieve
total mental effort than a single pair
of prints if I'm just adding two
like if you just aggregate to one on top
of each other um yeah so keep in mind
this graph isn't I mean I just drew it
in power points oh I capably the
Crashdown word is lower I don't have
exact numbers for that but yeah yeah I
mean and that's the reason this is ipod
this is because you don't have data at
least in the ethnographic form that
allows us to make that assessment but
yes I agree that's very interesting
perspective okay and the last one does a
bit on social psychology as the idea
that pair programmers are facing the
cost of constant evaluation by a
knowledgeable partner which in a lot of
social psychology studies have proved to
either facilitate or impede your
performance on a task depending on how
well learned or unwell learned that is
and so one thing that we suspected was
happening on here was it spurred by the
expectation of being evaluated ended
little programmers in the pair are
working to a higher standard of social
commitment so they force themselves
write better code they have more elegant
designs they don't settle for like the
hacky solution because they know
someone's going to be looking at and
being like what is that yeah videotape
them because do you think that that
changed
so in this sense in the ethnography they
were not being videotaped they're being
audio recorded and I didn't tell them I
had a CS degree so actually they they
thought they would like over explained
it all to me and stuff like that because
so that idea was that I was trying to
reduce how much I evaluation at pension
I would not the p-value yes well I
watched them over three months for over
40 hours so I mean in some sense
probably the first time but over time
you tend to drop that one thing I did
notice again from my other study of
solar programmers is that the first time
I was with a solar programmer they never
goofed off from the entire like five
hour period that I was sitting behind
them but the second or third time people
were watching Star Trek videos while I
was sitting there running a tape
recorder surfing the web so reading
Wikipedia so I think after they can't
sustain not basically okay so um all
right back well we're in the process of
doing now is trying to take all this
information and pare it down into
something that we can then translate
into a lab study so i'll talk a little
bit about what's challenges that are
facing us and what we hope to get out of
a lab study so what can a laboratory
experiment tell us that an ethnographic
study cannot and i'm kind of touched on
this as i talk through the hypotheses
one thing is isolation and control the
factors are inherently co-found
confounded in the workplace right the
lab environment potentially allows us to
really isolate and look at a particular
factor or at least control for certain
factors across the different pairs that
we're studying it allows independent
replication me and for all we know that
maybe these two teams are actually just
completely weird right does this
behavior this the same dynamic occur
across multiple programmers coming from
different backgrounds is something
that's inherent to pair of orienting
themselves or is it something that's a
function of XP or the team set up in
this particular developed environments I
mean that's not on the slide the club
also gives us his performance measures I
couldn't get them to let me look at the
code so now i have no performance
ratings for the pairs that i was
observing and so the
I would let us take the code that they
write and actually be like who has lower
defect rates who completed things faster
Hoover better code so then what we're
facing is how will we translate these
observations and speculations hypotheses
into a series of experiments that's
appropriate for the lab laboratory
environment and relevant to management
and development developers so we have to
kind of challenges facing us one of them
is recruitment we want to run the study
on professional programmers but they are
difficult to recruit and as you all know
their time is very expensive and then
the challenge of face validity there's
an inherent tension being able to
isolate a particular factor for study in
the lab with how closely whatever tasks
we have them do is going to resemble a
real work task or a real work
environment so those are two talentos
let me talk a little about the resources
we have available to us the first one is
the Stanford CDR design observatory
which is a great lab the video analysis
that Larry referred to kind of gave
fruit to this it's a lab that allows us
to put developers inside kind of a
fishbowl room we have four cameras
running at them to capture a different
angle so here you see their computers in
that one but in this case this is our
pair programming set up so we have one
to look at the screens we have what
their dash lee facing so you can see
expression a different angle on the
screen and an overhead view to capture
although that's actually a little bit
off we meant to slide it that way to see
what they were writing and drawing as
they were coding and so that gives us
kind of it also we also have continuous
stream cat the screen capture as they're
working and audio capture of what
they're saying as they work so this
gives us a really much more complete
picture than we got in the workplace of
what's actually going on it allows for a
lot more micro analysis of behaviors for
instance interruption recovery right we
can now time based on their gesture and
where their gaze is looking at when
they've turned their attention back to
the computer which is not come through
in the written and a body idea the other
thing we did was we developed a video
analysis tool in order to handle all
this stuff it's called vaca
and it handles all these streams of
information allows you to identify and
categorize behaviors much as we did with
the written transcripts only with video
and audio synchronize this time and I
don't have a lot of detail map but it is
available on the net so if you go on
sourceforge you can see the source code
and talk to the the other re on the
project he's working on this okay so
based on these that kind of came up with
we can with a bunch of experiment ideas
and then paired them down to kind of the
three most feasible ones which are the
ones I'm going to talk briefly about
right now and each of them answers a
different question so one of these we
really struggled with on this project is
pair programming is a pretty nascent
phenomenon there hasn't been a lot of
in-depth research on it so what do we
really want to try and say with this one
opportunity we have to create a lad
study and so I'll talk about each of the
three the first one our guiding question
was a very basic one can we replicate
workplace behavior in the design
observatory so is this stuff going on in
a way that is inherent to two people on
any programming task when you tell them
to pair or their other stuff that's
going on so the idea here would be to
bring programmers into lab complete a
work realistic task or maybe three or
four hours and then vary some aspect of
the configuration or the task may be
sort of like poking ants with a stick to
see what happens all right like give us
a different picture controlled
ethnography well of what's going on in
that lab and the basic idea would be
verified that the mechanisms occurred
through i couldna graphic observations
still occur in the lab we get to measure
the effect of a controlled intervention
on these behaviors and then correlate
this behavior measure to pair
performance so again more verification
rather than truly new right see what if
we found in the field translate celeb
experiment be we took looking at the
interruption behavior again real
surprise to us we didn't expect to see
this in there but the pair's really
recover more rapidly and more
effectively from interruptions and solos
as I mentioned before we really didn't
have that great of a picture of what
they were doing pre and post
interruption in the ethnography not down
to like gesture and gaze and posture the
lab gives us an opportunity to do that
to really be able to say like
cognitively
we think changes are going on so we can
bring pear and soul of programmers in to
complete a work-related tasks interrupt
them periodically as they work control
the nature and the time of the
interruptions we didn't have any control
of that in the workplace environment
obviously and then try to better
understanding that and that impact on
program performance so this gives us a
better picture of that particular
phenomenon programming data so this is
pretty interesting because there hasn't
been a lot of studies on interruptions
on pairs in particular or on pair
programmers but it doesn't really
address the question we kind of set out
to talk about right which was the where
and why of pair programming in general
and it definitely doesn't explain pair
programming improvements and non
interruptive environment so
interruptions are never mentioned in the
previous studies although they're done
on students in the classrooms for
presumably they're getting interrupted
as they work as well but that's never
been captured okay and the last one that
we had again these are kind of random
cuts we did a lot of brainstorming had
to filter down for this talk so last one
it was how much of this pairing effect
comes from social facilitation can we
bring two programmers into right and
evaluate small pieces of code alone and
in pairs compare the quality and
evaluation ratings across different
conditions as well as across different
levels of expertise if I pair you with a
first-year student if I pair you with
someone I tell you has ten years of
experience that's considered an expert
in the field does that change how you
code and try to sort of isolate that
compared to the effects of knowledge
pulling problem negotiation so two
issues with that one we saw is that the
effect might not quite be strong enough
might be very subtle so we might need a
big sample in order to do side effect
and the second one is that when we start
talking about writing and evaluate some
piece of code we're getting at a very
narrow slice of that phenomenon we're
not really capturing the heart of
everything in preparing mean it's just
taking one small slice and maybe at this
early stage we want to you know go for a
bigger piece instead of trying to hone
in so much on one small one and I think
that's it mmhmm yeah request and what
by social facilitation its name that is
what may be confusing here is what we
talked about terminology shoes social
facilitation is determinate arises at a
social psychology and the idea is simply
that the expectation of evaluation by a
knowledgeable other changes your
behavior in some way shape or form and
so their studies are like for instance
if you have you have little kids tying
shoes and you put someone in the room
watching them tie shoes they'll tie
their shoes faster but if you don't have
someone if it's and then if you know no
one's in the room with them stuff like
that so it's just the sheer effective
devaluation pressure what I ask that all
right yeah the first one Thursday really
just basically spending whether care
programming is study of all right
because what do you meant o'clock
and then the second one is
yeah this one is a little bit weirder
because we're really again trying to
take it yeah and sometimes this one
assumes that that you can do that in the
lab if you I mean they're not really
doing anything here that really
resembles pair programming be doing
small tasks because the problem is if
you have them actually write programs
together right then the knowledge
pooling kind of comes in the problem to
go she a tip that kind of comes in so
you can't really isolate that slice in
there any other questions okay so I'm
going to turn it back over to Larry oh
yeah this actually looks surprisingly to
me like the same study that of work that
was done my friend ropes back in the 70s
mm-hmm and his conclusion was not this
that you do not take two people and
place them on the same past you take a
rock star put a team around them it
might be an interdisciplinary team and
by doing that you allow the rock star
essentially kick butt while the other
people clean up
conclusion I think also during that
process looked also at this same effect
and I'm wondering if you sort of studied
some of that early work and
there might be room for improvement that
early study I don't remember the brook
study enough detail to address that absa
mythical man yeah I've heard I just
don't remember the details of suspicion
stated observation was that it's the
surgical team where you have been chief
surgeon and then from the chief surgeon
you have the cutters of sutures the
other anesthesiologist and other people
around that team and so if you model
that transfer into programming you may
have the same kind of condition mm-hmm I
will say so one potential difference is
that Brooks was really kind of trying to
find the ideal team configuration right
there are compelling reasons outside of
that to use pairs potentially from one
is the distribution of knowledge on your
team if you have two people that write a
piece of code instead of one person if
that one person gets hit by a bus you
solve another person and conceivably
that knowledge is spread out more to
team that's a reason that's cited to us
often by the people on these teams that
are working in pairs so if you're not
looking at it from the perspective of
what is the most optimal way to write
software right but well optimal for a
slightly different definition of optimal
right then this phenomenon might be an
interesting thing and the other thing
that we thought when we were going
through this is like what can pair
programming tell us about better
supporting solo programmers right what
can you get from looking at the way
pairs work that can then come back and
be like what can we do in tools and
other designs the better support solos
from that yeah there was a
your progress
power
this gives bearing a bunch of Bruce's
mary has a beginner's mind and they
found that that actually having real
beginners on particular
task was cause more productivity that
having like machinist
the counters
I love to take like that study get me
the records okay any other questions I
should really give it to Larry so we'll
take one more and then if anyone is your
questions they can actually end along
are you sure okay so what it's always
that take questions that I've got a fair
question we'd always better have
questions you saw that data point up
there right got it ask question okay
John tells me we can take a bit of time
to ask what's next in terms of extreme
collaboration not just extreme program
extreme collaboration so a quick walk
through a quad chart essentially on
where's the Innovation Opportunity most
production work is over here and you're
with its production code that runs it
goes in the product in my will that's
the engine bell that goes in the cards
of manufacturing finessing it's designed
by the numbers we know the product we
know the process get the damn thing out
the counterpoint to that is the
innovation front end the architecture
front end we don't know want the
products of the deal we're not sure how
we should do what the few things we do
understand it's the foggy notion of what
would happen next that's where a lot of
the breakthrough stuff is it's when we
go into new markets owns that are often
rather than at least in particular to me
I want to point out to other zones that
are often not really looked at the
product we have the problem we know very
well what the product should do we know
how to get out to the market what's the
channel what's what's the packaging
that's the aunt of fedora we have a
process we know how to make movies well
very good at that senton million send a
decent script you got a movie in 10
weeks
we don't know how to do the product we
don't know what the product is okay so
this has turned out to be a striking the
important zone of renovation and ideal
product development consumer products
but they make movies audi makes cars
they get their cars and movies and it
stretches them up here it's look it's
the business sector that's driving you
there's a market as a mark I got this
now how do we get today I hope you got
the feeling for it it's the feeling I
want to get across because it's going
after the next generation in design /
architecture that I want to share with
you very brief we have a new Institute
at Stanford this particular slide
doesn't give the proper name for it so
I'll speak at verbally it's a hustle
plotner Institute of Design at Stanford
how many people recognize that the name
know a few fewer than I might have
expected because this gentleman comes
from the world of software and he has
invested heavily in our community to
bootstrap his organization to bring the
software development the kind of
innovation and user centric values that
have driven I do in our design program
in product innovation so just share some
images but you'll quickly see that the
image that you're just about people and
brainstorming getting people to bend
their brains together this has become
the icon we wanted a school at Stanford
what it was it going to be I don't know
there's a Venn diagram at the top that
tells you what what it needs to be there
people this guy even gets a role in it
and we've got to raise millions and
millions to make all this happen how
we're going to do it it's a lot this is
the icon for people working together
these are the crazy guys who make up the
startup organization a machinist a rock
star he happens to a founded ideal a
manager and operations guy who makes
sure the stuff gets delivered Oh hard
core academic guy studies people and how
they think a business school guy it's
all by the number is very very analytic
an applied mathematician who likes
people
a guy who doesn't like people but he
likes to study the organization's of
people that's not a fair statement I go
back one computer scientist who is
driven to develop better tools for
designer the people who have to create
the alternative futures of the world he
wants to give them better tools I think
that's pretty close to much of what you
folks do it's about people and it's
about the intersection of the
disciplines it's way beyond mechanical
engineering Electrical Engineering or
software in fact engineers are just a
little piece of the Venn diagram it's
all those other people that are part of
successful organizations design thinking
what is it it's almost always driven by
working on projects being embedded in
project working in small teams who blend
their minds open their souls trust each
other great things that can't be created
in individual minds I have no idea what
they're trying to do there with that
guy's mind
a familiar phrase everybody in our
business has to be a lifelong learner I
remember the noun phrase things every
single project has to create learning
and the more we learn the more quickly
and efficiently we learn the better or
product outcomes notice this little line
maybe can't read it each student is
encouraged to develop their own personal
process versus adapting to some standard
process and now that each person in this
room has come up with unique way of
creating new products new ideas
implementing them now we come together
in teams and the team is Richard because
we are the diversity of styles
approaches skill and knowledge okay slow
down so the Venn diagram wheels I think
I saw one earlier today most of us come
in this room from the technology set
that we build stuff it's feasible to
make what you want typically we then I'm
going to the business community try to
build organizations at a company that
can deliver the goods that make a profit
that are sustainable often lastly we
come to the human services come here
that human values community is really
good for people is it usable did we get
surprised in the light what had happened
and the d.school is trying to bring
design thinking to this diversity of
participant that's the extreme
collaborations in aisle so when we give
courses there are students from all
those areas brought together to focus on
how to do the thinking that would
deliver these outcomes so when the
course is running right now students
from these different departments and
disciplines we provide a physical place
where they can come and work together we
provide management skills organizational
skills logistics and mostly we coach
them to think
about creating alternative future the
creation side to counterbalance the
analytic side of most formal education
right now we're in a build cycle to put
up new spaces that facilitate that kind
of thinking the average building this
may be been one of them doesn't
facilitate that sort of open
communication and interaction we have
one building on campus the second one's
going up and that's the first technical
barrier to effective innovation
especially working
we're replacing the product build lab
not replacing we're augmenting the
product build lab with the product
experience lab this happens to be a
learning experience in this picture it's
very human centered the video recording
of the world the absorb salvation of the
world that building empathy for the user
getting into the issue is living the
life of a client literally a part of the
methodology I'm perhaps one of the most
distinctive features is the notion of
prototyping I know you lots of
prototyping in the software industry and
it would take a long discussion to sort
out just what it's about but before you
try to figure out what the perfect
solution is go build a crummy version of
it see what happens does it take you in
the right direction we'll have origins
in the mechanical world would build this
stuff almost all the stuff we build
today is computer mediated build cycles
so there's a prototyping culture of
testing your ideas and learning more
from your mistakes than from your
successes last year we did a prototype
course in which the engineer of the
design teams were challenged to develop
zhiting for rural india where there's no
electricity and this is a team in the
field about a thousand units were built
when the student team finished at
10-week exercise they raised five
million start a company in india built
tested and matured the product there so
part of this notion of extremeness to
take on really tough problem not just
finesse last year's version be a little
smoother but go out and change the world
so that's part of this overall motion
that we can do more we can do better we
can be more creative we're mostly going
to get there if we do it together
and we're only going to figure out how
by trying it's kind of a funny notion we
should work together but from pair
programming to the business sector to
working with clients in the world that
can't afford our stuff we think that's
what's hot and we hope there's a case
for doing some projects with you guys in
the future we'll see what happened
that's it Jan and I would be delighted
to take questions take suggestions and
actually have to do that at 45 per
minute I don't know if you caught this I
just saw it the first time and in gems
it showed the time to deal with an
interrupt was about one minute fifty or
one minute something I almost came out
you could do 45 interrupts so it's quite
every questions and interrupt on your
thought every time my child I know
challenge but I raise something then you
have to turn your head and look another
direction and then you bounce it back
you know what if and then that's the
kind of dialogue that is so fundamental
and valuable to creative activity
actually it's creative activity that
produces useful outcome it's not just
wild-haired crater this is creative to
make the damn product work or more
precisely and solve the problem that
needed to be solved
excellent but I have no doubts here
microphone if you would please speak to
the tale land that's not really a mic
that's just a the antenna let you have
to speak to that end no not to that to
get to the button end of the device go
go perfect so my questions actually by
your open collaborative spaces to
Microsoft initiative not also i'm
curious what you you mentioned i'm
telling officers front yards of back
porches particularly more than what
those mean those are open collaborative
terms and just what you're thinking is
on a flexible your station
about the space about flexibility of the
keyword were so telling and here's a
condensed version the intent of the
space is to be a place where students
and faculty from across the university
could come together typically units of
engagement of 10 weeks were on a quarter
system so you assemble teams you give
them a place to live and work Hotel them
the end of the period they're gone we
record lots of that we do audio and
video recording reading those wallboards
brainstorm sessions wikis blogs
everything else too from the research
for that perspective to better
understand how it worked and what didn't
work some projects will be longer its
project will have maybe a different mix
of disciplines and will have to
accumulate different kinds of knowledge
as some project may have to accumulate
architectural fragments it's going to
need a lot of space another project is
just accumulating code it just needs a
big discharge eat so those will flex
overtly no wall will be fixed most walls
when they're there will be transparent
one of the killer issues recording
decent audio so we have to have some
acoustically isolated spaces it's just
possible that will end up that everybody
wears a headset all the time when in a
building partly to get a decent record
and party because that's maybe the way
we'll live pretty soon
one of the things we find is
terrifically supportive of high
intensity teams that are co-located and
that's if they put their knowledge in
the environment it puts slides no it's
post it's garbage whatever it is it put
it up so they can see it and remember it
and oh yeah that piece over there when
you talked about it all those things
help us juggle more more frameworks and
more ideas / you at a time so that these
spaces have to be able to store
knowledge and be able to get rid of it
again that's actually one of the really
hard challenges I happen to know ideas
work they have a large architectural
design group being able to make work
environment that allow rich temporary
storage of stuff in the environment and
then let go of it again it's a technical
challenge its a exits a lifestyle
challenge quickly illustrated with most
of you have offices with sound absorbing
wolf take them all the way what do you
get whoo you got a lot more interaction
just eyeball to eyeball I can see you
now you get a lot more noise and all
your stuff is exposed and one of the
solutions they came up with is instead
of us having offices where we store our
stuff we have walls on the side of the
room where we've common we store our
stuff in common say your books are next
to my books and next to Jan's books and
when you look for a book you can see
what everybody's got and they use that
in their own architectural space its
bits one example it worked for them
about collective access to each other's
knowledge base or experience base we
think is more important
good question you're getting into a new
building or some of you are I heard
reference to it this morning so I jumped
on that yeah let's go redesign that
building whatever they started they
probably didn't get a radical and here's
part of why i gotta say that facilities
engineering community looks at a
building and sees a 50 year life cycle
do they want you to mess with it every
year change it around absolutely not
they want to put it up and treat all of
us goes to come and go we don't have any
role in the building and how it operates
then i went through this on my own
campus it won't let us make a flexible
space because they're afraid actually
will do something with it and i think
your face for that too and the guy who's
hired after you want you there was too
many words for one question more
question yes did you think it all about
observation elaborate from the
collaboration i'm thinking visually
about this as a the two guys are sitting
working and you've got a big 50 inch
screen and you can watch what they're
working on from the open spaces with a
cup of coffee and is there a
collaborative environment that builds
around that that supports the
observational parts those people are not
integrated into the process but is that
mere act of observation going to be an
improvement over you know is that
justice i I hear a general concern if
you're observing if you will one is it
ethical one is it socially responsible
what is that could be honest and should
a work environment be manipulated to
serve the observer versus serve the
worker and I would work back with the
environments got to be for the people
working there if that big screens
helping down that's good if it's not
we're not going to it shouldn't be there
and then observation is only by it
should only be by permission and we're
an evolving world what we don't it it's
gettin slippery about one is an
observation taking place if something
can record my email and observe it later
if somebody can record your conditioning
settings in the room and report later
that this guide keep changing the
temperature that's a project we have
believe it or not if everybody in the
room had their own temperature
environment there's some data out there
that says we get a ten percent
productivity improvement then we'd start
recording the temperature settings the
world of in the social sciences and
where the issue of observation is most
frequently dealt with they have very
quickly they have rigorous approaches to
to keeping track of when and how you
observe curiously in engineering we seem
to be more open to being observed than
social scientists on we had a major
project where we instrumented a works in
there was mostly technical people and
they had no problem there was the
cameras on
all the time that's cool I want to look
at the record too and then we brought in
the anthropologist who might have
benefited from that material and they
said yeah that's okay but not the camera
that could see me and they literally
taped over the cameras we had we shut
that down follow up in do you think
that's peculiar to a discipline like
mechanical engineering separate from
I'll call it the more private
observation of what the way programmers
normally work one mental described as
opposed to the physical gestural of
effect that you see in mechanical
engineering their disciplinary biases
both in who tends to go into the fields
what they're thinking styles are work
styles are they are different we have to
finesse this each time for each group
part of what we're exploring here is it
more and more these disciplines have to
be professionally qualified you're going
to have to be able to work with others
and that'll become part of professional
development it'll be part of what you
get in school you'll be led to
understand that that's okay and that's
valuable you don't have to paint
yourself a different color but you might
decide to well developing some of those
skills okay I learned I learned what I
learned the history of states maybe I
should learn a bit of a history of
southern China or so that wasn't a good
example but as we increasingly work in
cross-cultural teams we are now
extending the coaching model to being
not just technical advice and process
advice but helping to understand
cultural variables in the workforce
that's a whole nother subject I think it
will become more and more comfortable
and it could even be some really sizable
change for the time when we need to work
alone maybe we'll get an allocation from
the company to have a first-rate office
at home but when we come to work will
know that okay I'm in the workplace now
we're going to it's going to be this
shared interactive scenario and just one
little footnote because it was triggered
by some of the questions that the social
facilitation issue I think that makes us
uncomfortable but and if you look at
high performance athletic teams nobody
would dream of trying to put a peak
performance team on the basketball court
where everybody wasn't fired up and
committed to winning that game and
something each other and helping each
other and sure they're i'm watching to
see if you screw up i miss you know
throw the ball through me I thought I
guy we accept that there without problem
and I think it's conceivable we would
accept it and it's in a more
intellectual zone as well I'm sure we
should cut it this point so thank you
all very much Jen and I appreciate the
opportunity to be with you we had great
conversations this morning where we were
absorbing and hope we gave something
back